l'alberta se vante d'être libre de rats
une situation pratiquement unique au
monde
mais à part peut-être l'antarctique elle
compte en partie sur sa géographie
singulière montagnes à l'ouest
tundra au nord désert des badlands au
sud et à l'est la prairie plein de
culture du grain certes dont les rangs
sont friands mais ceux ci se déplacent
ordinairement d'habitation à
l'habitation est ici les villages sont
distants souvent de dizaines de
kilomètres il ne reste donc qu'une
petite bande de vulnérabilité ou
l'europe mettre le bout du nez long du
sud-est sur une trentaine de kilomètres
dans la région de vénétie nat et c'est
là qu'attend la patrouille duras prêt à
bondir à la moindre alerte en 2002
l'alberta a été déclaré pour la première
fois dans son existence sans infestation
de rats entre 2002 2005
il n'y a eu que deux infestation de
reconnu mais depuis les rangs semble
prendre pied la province considère que
les infestations plus importante de 2012
2014 au nombre de plus de 20 notamment
sont inhabituelles on a même découvert
un nid de 80 mètres de long on n'a pas
de rats en alerte
parce qu'on en a jamais vraiment et
quand ils sont arrivés on les a attaqués
à vaincre le citalys dans la province le
responsable de la patrouille des reins
en alberta fait rumeurs la saskatchewan
fait un très bon travail de dératisation
et deux tiers des municipalités rurales
n'ont pas de roues alors il ya un an -
drap viennent de l'est
et quant à l'occasion on voit des rats
on s'y attaque tout on note une
augmentation des populations de rats
également à vancouver et maintenant
comme le montrent ces images à toronto
la plus grande ville du canada des
chercheurs de l'université de la
colombie britannique
sur la côte ouest canadienne suggère
donc aux villes de se doter d'une
politique globale de lutte contre les
rats les villes pourraient s'inspirer en
partie du temps du programme de
dératisation mise en place dans les
années 50 par l'alberta le problème avec
les rats c'est qu'ils véhiculent des
maladies on peut comparer les rats à d
éponge qui absorbe les pathogènes ils
peuvent absorber dans nos environnements
des pathogènes qui affecte les humains
les propager nous affecter à nouveau
chelsea et -9 et vétérinaires et chef
d'un projet de recherche sur des rats
à vancouver on a trouvé chez les
personnes vivant dans le quartier le
plus pauvre de vancouver des sujets
spécifiques de staphylocoques résistants
et on l'a trouvée chez les rats du
quartier exactement la même souche de
staphylocoque résistant aux
antibiotiques
on a aussi trouvé chez sert à la
bactérie c difficile et une souche de e
coli résistants qui affecte aussi les
humains alors selon nous ça démontre que
les rats sont eux plus grand danger pour
notre santé que ce qu'on a cru jusqu'à
mais pour le moment l'alberta se dresse
comme seul rempart efficace contre la
propagation des rangs au canada
géographie heureusement joué un rôle
mais l'ingéniosité humaine aussi
toujours un pas au-devant des rats sinon
un pas en arrière
un reportage de radio canada
international